whether they feature shocking twists or
important character developments these
Sequel and prequel moments made it
impossible for us to watch our favorite
movies and shows the same way again
it's safe to say that the truth about
Darth Vader that he used to be Anakin
Skywalker is no longer much of a spoiler
but it sure was back in 1980. it's
probably the most famous twist in sci-fi
history and it wasn't even in the
filmmaker's original plans judging by
earlier versions of the script George
Lucas had initially intended for Darth
Vader and Anakin to be two separate
characters the idea didn't even occur to
him until he was working on The Empire
Strikes Back And The Twist was
originally proposed as a joke according
to Marcia Lucas yet amazingly so many
things from the original movie make
sense in retrospect in fact fans can
re-watch the scene from A New Hope where
Obi-Wan tells Luke about Anakin and
finds several clues that suggest the old
Master wasn't telling the whole truth
even if they were purely coincidental
when Obi-Wan tells Luke about Uncle
Owen's relationship with Anakin his
delivery suggests that he might be
hiding something important
he didn't hold with your father's ideals
thought he should have stayed here and
not gotten involved likewise when Luke
asks how his father died Obi-Wan pauses
noticeably before answering he is
technically lying when he tells Luke
that Vader betrayed and murdered Anakin
but if you want to be more generous you
could say that Obi-Wan is simply being
metaphorical
since the beginning of the MCU one thing
has seemed certain Shield is on the side
of the good guys after all the
organization assembled The Avengers and
consistently worked against malevolent
villains like Loki and the evil Hydra
organization however Captain America the
Winter Soldier changed all that as Steve
Rogers discovers that shield and Hydra
have become one in the same since the
events of the first Captain America
movie Hydra has slowly infiltrated the
ranks of shield and their hijacking
Shields weapons and resources to carry
out its agenda the sequel forces Captain
America to begin questioning Authority
and re-examine his assumptions about
right and wrong likewise it made Marvel
fans feel a little guilty for cheering
at Shield's previous victories fans will
realize with horror that Hydra must have
been working behind the scenes the whole
time even during the Battle of New York
in The Avengers Hydra grew right under
your nose and nobody noticed why do you
think we're meeting in this cave I
noticed
how many paid the price before you did
it's also worth noting that Captain
America the Winter Soldier set an
entirely new precedent for the MCU fans
no longer had to wait for the next
Avengers movie to see plot points that
would have a major impact on other
Marvel films this sequel proved that the
events of One Solo movie could Ripple
outward to affect the entire MCU
something we've seen many times since in
Finding Nemo dori's short-term memory
loss is pretty much just a running gag
sure it moves the plot forward and helps
Marlin become a better parent but it's
still mostly played for Laughs upon
watching Finding Dory though fans will
discover that The Lovable blue tang has
her own tragic backstory to tell Finding
Dory shows how much of a nightmare it
can be to live in constant fear that
you'll forget about the people you love
viewers can feel the pain of dory's
parents as they worry about how their
daughter will be able to take care of
herself and for the first time audiences
know what it's like to see the world
through dory's eyes in particular the
Montage at the beginning of the movie
which shows young Dory growing up alone
cements to viewers how little they truly
understood Dory in the first movie these
moments from Finding Dory add a whole
new layer to Finding Nemo if you watch
it again not only do we learn the
origins of her just keep swimming song
but her monologue in which she begs
Marlon not to leave her becomes even
more poignant when you realize just how
many people have left Dory before
likewise some of the jokes from the
first film will take on a much sadder
undertone I forget things almost
instantly it runs in my family well I
mean at least I think it does
fans who love the faithful Android
bishop and aliens are undoubtedly
devastated when the character dies in
Alien 3. however in the climax of the
third movie they find themselves
unsettled rather than joyous when Bishop
appears to be back from the dead it
turns out that this isn't Bishop rather
it's the man who built him known only as
Bishop 2 this employee of the Weyland
yutani Corporation designed the Android
to look exactly like him while the two
characters share the same face they
couldn't be more different Bishop is
willing to sacrifice himself to
savorably while Bishop 2 cares only
about harvesting the xenomorph inside of
her
Bishop 2 isn't an Android program to
carry out the bidding of the company
he's an actual human being who sees the
xenomorph as a magnificent specimen
Bishop 2 is just as cunning and callus's
Ash from the first movie but what makes
this man somehow worse is that you
almost want to believe him how can you
not when he has Bishop's face if you
re-watch aliens after seeing this moment
from Alien 3 you'll never be able to
look at Bishop the same way again Norman
from don't breathe certainly seems like
a victim at first glance after all he's
just a blind man who comes across as
pretty defenseless after three teenagers
break into his home yet as the movie
unfolds it becomes increasingly clear
that Norman is the villain the sequel
don't breathe two subverts expectations
once again early in the movie viewers
see the young girl Phoenix running from
Norman's dog it seems like Phoenix will
be Norman's next victim until the movie
reveals that Phoenix is actually
Norman's adoptive daughter and he is
simply training her how to survive fans
may be surprised to discover that Norman
is actually a protective albeit icy Dad
it's especially shocking to see Phoenix
be friendly to the dog that was so
terrifying in the original film
I snap my fingers and he'll bite your
testicles off now Norman is shown as
less a villain and more of an anti-hero
it seems he has moved away from
kidnapping and rape and has found a more
tasteful way of having a child of his
own he rescued Phoenix from a fire and
raised her himself Norman is still
definitely ruthless and terrifying but
he's not quite the monster he was in the
prequel it may be difficult for viewers
to reconcile these two sides of Norman
whether you feel that don't breathe two
is humanizing a three-dimensional
character or trying to excuse the
actions of a Despicable one one thing's
for sure it will completely change how
you watch the first film
Jimmy McGill more commonly known as Saul
Goodman may just seem like a crooked
lawyer in Breaking Bad but the prequel
series Better Call Saul adds a whole new
layer to his character
becoming Albuquerque's scummiest
attorney Jimmy is deeply insecure he
craves approval from his brother Chuck a
once great lawyer who never leaves the
house anymore due to his allergy to
electricity even at his lowest though
Chuck is still more respected than Jimmy
but the scene from Better Call Saul that
reveals the most about Jimmy is the
moment from the sixth and final season
when Kim breaks up with him it's
especially heartbreaking because she
admits that really she does still love
him but they can never be together again
we are bad for everyone around us other
people suffer because of us the breakup
is the final straw that completes
Jimmy's transformation into Saul knowing
this about Saul his callous behavior and
Breaking Bad is a bit more
understandable with such a tragic
backstory it's easy to see why he's
willing to sell out his own clients like
when he urges Walter to kill badger in
order to save his own skin this may also
explain why Saul is flirting with Skyler
one minute and then telling her he can't
imagine how she and Walter are still
married the next perhaps Saul is a bit
jealous that Walter managed to maintain
his marriage for as long as he did
aside from being a mightily satisfying
payoff for Marvel's Infinity Saga
Avengers end game also enriches the
previous films in the MCU by changing
how we view moments from other movies
The Time Heist at the center of the film
allows fans to revisit several iconic
MCU scenes alongside their favorite
Heroes but this time they're seen from
different angles for instance the
introduction of Guardians of the
Galaxy's Peter Quill is hilariously put
in perspective when we see it Through
The Eyes of nebula and Roadie so he's an
idiot
yeah meanwhile the trip to 2012 New York
has some more surprises in store who
would have guessed there would be an
epic Captain America versus Captain
America battle in The Avengers tower
that was conveniently omitted from The
Avengers
in addition the movie reminds us that
the hydra-controlled shield had always
been lurking in the background of the
MCU perhaps the most head spinning
reveal is that after the events of
endgame Steve Rogers goes back in time
so he can be reunited with Peggy and
grow old this means that Peggy Carter's
husband as mentioned in the Winter
Soldier is none other than cap the
screenwriters of Avengers end game have
confirmed that Rogers was indeed the
father of Peggy's kids
when choosing a villain for the movie
Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan the
filmmakers turned to the original TV
series
after defeating the genetic Superman
Khan in the episode space seed Captain
Kirk Exiles Khan and his people to the
uninhabited Planet seti Alpha 5. however
Kirk never bothers to check on them so
he doesn't realize that Khan ends up
spending a decade and a half in an
uninhabitable Wasteland the sequel film
demonstrates that Kirk's well-meaning
actions can have far-reaching
consequences the sequel sets a totally
different tone from the Original Series
right from the opening scene in which
Lieutenant savic makes the decision to
rescue the imperiled Kobayashi Maru from
a neutral zone endangering the entire
crew of the Enterprise
for a moment it seems like the Klingons
have killed everybody including Spock
but a surprise entrance from Kirk
reveals that the whole thing was just a
simulation although viewers are relieved
to learn that none of what they just saw
was real the opening sequence shows fans
a darker and more mature version of the
Star Trek universe it's a painful
reminder that the crew of the Enterprise
might one day need to face a no-win
scenario like the one shown in the
simulation and that everyone's a
redshirt at the end of the day Spock
actually dies for real later in the
movie and even though he's resurrected
in the sequels both his fake and real
deaths have had lasting impacts on the
Star Trek universe
a running gag in the Big Bang Theory is
the roommate agreement that has been
established between Sheldon and Leonard
this is a contract that the two
roommates have signed to spell it what
they can and cannot do while living
together and Sheldon never hesitates to
cite the exact Clauses that he feels
Leonard is violating I'm here because
you violated our roommate agreement
specifically Section 8 visitor
subsection see females paragraph four
coitus a scene from Young Sheldon
explains where Sheldon first got this
idea as a kid and it allows fans to
understand why Sheldon cares so much
about contracts into his adulthood
according to the episode vanilla ice
cream gentleman collars and a dinette
set Sheldon's first contract is created
to help his Memaw while she's dating Dr
Sturgis Sheldon can't help but overhear
the two arguing and he also can't help
spying on them with binoculars he wants
things to work out between Mima and her
new boyfriend so he offers to draft a
relationship contract so the couple can
establish boundaries If this
relationship is going to have any chance
at all we have to lay down some ground
rules great I love rules I do too it's a
sweet gesture from Sheldon that shows
how much he truly loves his Memaw of
course this sentimental moment doesn't
hold a candle to a certain other scene
from The Big Bang Theory involving
Sheldon and his Memaw fans are sure to
find Amy's Christmas cookie gift extra
Bittersweet after watching that
particular episode of Young Sheldon
foreign